You sound like a
pathologically terrible dad.
And now you have a podcast called Dads
and it's on my podcast
network and you're hosting.
And this is a podcast where
it's not just a podcast for dads.
You're talking about a
lot of different issues
involving fatherhood, is that correct?
That is correct.
Myself and Ruthie Wyatt, who you know,
we cohost the show together
and we have on different
guests like yourself.
Today is the first episode that drops.
And for everyone who listens,
Conan made us have him on.
He said, if you want this thing to work,
you gotta have the hot
stuff right up front.
[Conan] Yup.
So he was our first episode.
And yeah we talk about being a dad.
We talk about having a dad.
It's not just for dads though.
We also have non-dads on
the show that we interview
to get perspectives about parenting
and their relationships
with their dads or stepdads.
Yeah, I had a really
good time talking to you.
And like I said, I did
think it was important
when you launch a podcast,
you have to have the hot stuff.
That's what I said.
And that is available for everybody
wherever you get your podcasts.
You can check out our
interview with Conan right now.
And then once a week, we'll
be releasing a new episode.
We have so many coming up, John Leguizamo,
David Cross, Sabrina
Jalees, Vanessa Ragland,
the list goes on and on.
Andrew Richter, one of our guests.
We call him Andy.
Not me.
He makes me call him Andrew.
Sir Andrew Richter.
Sir?
You have to call him Sir Andrew Richter?
Wow.
Yeah, I asked, I was like,
don't you have to be knighted?
But he said that is
technically his first name.
Andrew is his middle name.